Hi there,
it's only about a week before Christmas
and some of you are no doubt scrambling
to determine what might make an
appropriate Christmas gift.
As you may know or also may not.
I have written a book that's coming out
in January on January 23rd as a matter
of fact called 12 rules for life and
antidote to chaos and it's possible that
some of the people you know might be
interested in receiving that as a gift.
However,
a promise to get a book a month later,
it doesn't make a great Christmas gift.
Exactly.
So what I've done is put together a
small package that announces that the
book has been ordered that has a short
letter in it for me and also that
contains the introduction to the book
about 10 pages,
which I called over tour.
You could order the book online from any
of the vendors to whom I have provided a
link in the description of the video and
you could also download the package I
produced and print it out to make the
gift more tangible and therefore more
well solid and appreciated,
I would say.
And then you could put it in an envelope
and you can give that little package as
a gift,
and maybe that would be more appropriate
than a mere indication that the book is
on its way.
So I hope that's useful.
Thank you all for tuning in over the
last year and before that,
and for all the support you've offered
to be in the last year and a merry
Christmas and happy new year.
Yes.